as storytellers we are always searching
for incredible sources of pressure to
put on our character you're working on a
war game on a military on a shooter
you're kind of go to Guinea source of
pressure is an enemy that is trying to
shoot at you and then within a few
warfare having a lot of the missions
take place outside of our breathable
atmosphere that just puts even more
pressure on you now you have an
environment that's trying to kill you as
well you know if you can't breathe
you don't know which way is up if you
don't have normal gravity these are all
things that are conspiring against you
as a player conspiring against your
squad and it just adds to that pressure
and we're always looking for those
ultimate sources of pressure because
when you have those ultimate sources of
pressure all the niceties go out the
window and you really know what makes a
person tick and revealing that true
nature of these people that's
storytelling in a nutshell and that's
the kind of stuff that we look for as
sort of as a way to educate ourselves
going through our own lives there are
three studios taking turns on the annual
Call of Duty franchise two years ago it
was sledgehammer games with an advanced
warfare
last year it was Treyarch with black ops
3 and now in 2016 it's time for Infinity
Ward the studio that started the
franchise in the first place
to take its turn with the ubiquitous
shooter series and although Call of Duty
draws millions of players with its
fast-paced progression heavy multiplayer
modes Infinity Ward looked elsewhere
when developing infinite warfare it
looked to the single-player campaign not
just its structure and set peace moments
but also its story and how that story is
told
and in an effort to set this new
narrative apart Infinity Ward took to
outer space
first and foremost from a narrative
standpoint we wanted to tell a classic
war story in the great tradition
hopefully of a lot of the war stories
that have come before us in books and
movies and TV and we wanted to have
something that was sort of transcended
time or transcendent setting
so despite the stories new frontier it
is in many ways a return to Call of
Duty's World War two roots it's a story
of black and white good versus evil it's
the story about a massive sneak attack
and the resulting war that changes its
participants over time in a lot of
really well-received war stories the
story really centers on you and your
squad and what you guys are going
through and how you have each other's
backs and how the pressures of the war
and the enemy hunting you can reveal
things about your true nature
it's a stress
it's a pressure that's put on your guys
and and we think that's a very
interesting thing to to reveal well sure
saw in the drone captain's orders that
somebody and it's Bob not drone call me
Sara I work for a living
check your pop captain for a throw
Maddie a look well we wanted to tell a
story about the burden of leadership and
we wanted to tell a story about people
that cared about each other you know one
of the things that we recognized from
spending time and from some of them you
know we've been inspired by movies like
Black Hawk Down Saving Private Ryan
shows like Band of Brothers and one of
the takeaways as storytellers and and as
an actor as a writer are these
remarkable relationships
we're trying to be grounded we're trying
to be in this world what would really
happen to these people even though this
is a this is a future setting even
though this is a thing that's like you
know we don't really know what that's
gonna look like but we're we're saying
this is what it looks like and if that's
what it looks like and we're still
people how do these people react and how
do these moments occur and everything so
the bomb even in the bomb vest we were
trying to make it like this is
believable this is a thing that could
happen we're gonna reinforce these
characters and have these moments in a
level rather than in between levels and
we're gonna think about this arc of
character development and how that
changes over the course of the game more
than we've thought about that in the
past
members of the new Infinity Ward have
worked on several iconic series tomb
raider uncharted in the Last of Us to
name a few
Kurosaki himself came from Naughty Dog a
studio known for its storytelling
prowess he's helped shaped stories about
roguish treasure hunters and post
apocalyptic relationships and as was the
case with those stories the team working
on infinite warfare wants to morph not
just its narrative but how that
narrative affects the gameplay a big
tenant of this game was we wanted to
give the players some choices we wanted
to give the players mission choices and
we wanted to feel that you were leading
the charge so we created this character
of Reyes who is the captain of the
retribution you are the captain of your
own carrier and yeah that was a
challenge it was a challenge not having
the sort of fallback of a more senior
leader telling you where to go and what
to do ground assault captains places on
the bridge not this captain I think one
of the things that came out of ghosts
and some and some cod games we've built
over the past was this idea of playing a
strong leadership role rather than being
kind of one of the junior guys in the
crew a real big focus for us is making
sure that the player is in sync
emotionally with the protagonists
disrespected you don't let him under
your skin and the more successfully you
can do that the more bought into the
story and bought into the narrative and
bought into the characters the player
feels and the more closeness he feels
and the more care the player feels and
therefore again you have these set
pieces and the more emotional and more
kind of like impactful they are try and
stop me sir
in the beginning there was a lot of
prototyping going on around different
ideas and concepts and stuff like this
and a prototype that we did here that
they were working on that was really
about that kind of transition moment in
the in the game now the first time you
kind of take off from Geneva and that
launch sequence and that transition up
to that first big space battle that it's
kind of was kind of the essence of that
kind of cool idea the idea that you
could transition from something so
familiar like a like a storm the hill a
charged the hill moment a very kind of
mana warfare feeling moment through this
very kind of cinematic transition and up
and then into something that was totally
new and different there are going to be
moments of bombast they're gonna be huge
things that happen to these characters
and then they're also going to be synced
with things that seem smaller intimate
and more emotional and the the
juxtaposition between those two things
we feel that makes it a little bit more
impactful captain's dude used to get his
men on the lodge staff sergeant always a
tenant
always
if Infinity Ward succeeds the result
will be a mash-up of World War two
camaraderie spectacular blockbuster set
pieces and personal player driven
moments all outside the confines of
Earth's atmosphere a story with massive
scope but intimate focus Infinity Ward
was there right at Call of Duty's
inception in 2003 Infinity Ward was
there when the shooter entered modern
times in 2007 but in recent years the
Studios played somewhat of a tertiary
role to Treyarch and sledgehammer games
yet with infinite warfare with its focus
on narrative player choice in a bold
style of campaign storytelling Infinity
Ward hopes once again to take hold of
the franchise it began all those years
ago